having started out in musicals myself I
am particularly delighted at the
re-emergence of the big musical motion
picture two of this year's nominees for
Best Picture are musicals and the
Academy's Board of Directors has voted a
special Oscar for the craftsmen who make
our musicals dance as well as sing the
choreographer the recipient of this
special award is Miss Oona white the her
choreographer for Oliver
you all recognize me young man to place
Oliver
it's the first time for everything and
this is my first time tonight on
Broadway
I've had seven on the nation's never one
and what a marvelous way to win one with
this special I want to thank every one
in the Academy and everyone concerned
with all of them I'd like to mention
each one but I'm afraid I'll forget
somebody so I'll just thank them all
collectively however we all want to make
special mention of the gentleman who
collected and guided us through the
whole thing Mike Frank ovitch I would
like also to thank my assistant Tom
panko who did a great deal and helped me
a lot
thank you very much and thank the
cutting again